- So here's my rant.
And I'll see you in three years.
I don't care if you buy an NFT.
I just don't care.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(hip hop instrumentals)
- Hey, this is the NonFunGerbils podcast
NFP with your host DKleine.
And today I have a very
special guest, GaryVee.
Welcome to the show.
- I really appreciate it.
Thank you for having me.
- Okay, this is wild.
I have to tell you.
I'm pretty excited about this.
I really appreciate you
making time for this.
- Thank you, thank you for
saying that, I'm flattered.
I'm really excited to be on it honestly.
- Yeah, I've noticed you're making
quite the deep dive into the whole
NFT art scene the last couple of days,
I've seen you all over the place.
I saw you on Crypto
Campfire the other day.
- Hmm!
- Tell me about, you know
it seems like when you're doing something
you just go full board at it.
- I really do.
And I really, you know, it's funny
people don't know this about me
because they see all the energy.
You know, what's so funny,
I think so much of the energy that I bring
has to do with the fact that usually, it's
because I've been pent up
for three to four months about
something I'm excited about, right?
So for example, you
know, with sports cards
which was something similar that I got
very passionate about, you know
I grew up passionate about it
and then I got very,
very passionate about it
about three years ago,
it was several,
several months,
maybe almost a year on that one
that I was doing real homework
before I had come out and said
this, that, and the other thing.
Now, I've been doing lightweight homework,
you know since probably this summer,
you know,
on NFTs.
The reason I bought
Ethereum in 2016 after Aaron
Battalion, big shout out to
Aaron Battalion former
CTO of Living Social,
great VC, great technologists,
educated me on it at South by Southwest.
Was basically the understanding
of the potential of what became NFTs.
Like I was like, Oh,
okay, this isn't currency
this is framer build
on time, you know like,
platform and so,
I think I get so loud and excited
'cause I've been wanting to
be loud and excited for months.
I basically do 60, 70%
of my knowledge base
before I say a word to the world.
- Hmm!
- For example, I've been doing that
with BR quite a bit, I'm very deep into BR
more than people think
'cause I never talk about.
Even this mentioned is
already a lot for me
by my standards, because
I don't like to talk
about things that I don't
know anything about.
Now, I don't mind to be in this place
where I'm like, hey, I have some real
opinions and understandings and thoughts
and hypotheses, comma.
There's still a lot of
things I need to know
to really feel comfortable the way I do
about social media or
wine or sports cards.
But I don't feel like I'll be embarrassed.
I feel like I understand my point of view
on what the consumers are
gonna do with that FT.
I feel like I can speak,
I can speak to
ERC-20 and ERC-721
and I can speak to crypto
punks and larva labs.
And I can speak to Pepe being a BTC
a Bitcoin version of like I can, you know,
I understand what wrapping is now.
Like, you know, like I can, I can
I can hang enough where I'm not wasting
people's time because what I'm great at
according to my mother,
but in all seriousness what I'm
very comfortable with
is consumer behavior.
I mean, what I can say today,
for example, I can say
the following sentence
to an audience, you know, I'm picking
very specific places I wanna be on.
Podcast I know have a lot of time.
You know, DK. I do this show
because of the people you comma,
the people that I anticipate
listening to this show
which is a very authentic OG,
thoughtful, bright, kind community.
- It is.
It's an awesome thing.
- I know, I do a lot of homework,
so I feel very comfortable I know
who's listening right now, which is
people I admire is what
would be the word I use.
Comma, what I think I bring to the table
in 1995 when I went to dotcom
or email or Google AdWords or YouTube
or social or everything
I've done in my life
Madison Avenue's startup land,
I can bring things like,
hey everybody, listen.
And am just incredibly comfortable
to put this on the record,
NFT over the next 12 to 18 months
is gonna be very similar to ICO.
- Yep.
- 97% of these projects are gonna collapse
in secondary value.
It's gonna confuse
people, say it was a fad,
it was beanie babies.
Comma, the underlining
tech, and consumer behavior
is gonna be one of the
most significant things
that happens in modern technology.
- I'm with you.
- Cool, so like to me that's-
- I can relate.
- Yeah, please, please.
- Yeah.
- Take it away.
- I don't wanna take up too much of your-
- No, take it away.
- Time in the podcast
but 'cause it's your say
I had the same experience when I
learned about Bitcoin and Ethereum.
I literally spent a year learning about it
before I did anything about it.
And then I just couldn't
contain myself anymore.
And I began writing about it.
And that's how I got to
writing for "Coin Telegraph"
was just through blogging about it
and writing about it every day
until the point that
people noticed my writing.
And that's when last year
I had the opportunity
to write about crypto art in particular
and especially about
the trash art movement.
And that just flipped a switch for me
because I was like holy crap,
this is Marcel Duchamp.
This is data.
This is the beginning of-
- A 100%
- It's the beginning of modern art,
- 100%, 100%.
- It's a renaissance or a renaissance
of that same process yet
now in a digital era.
- And comma,
those artists made peanuts.
- Yeah.
- In the scheme of the economics
that happened over the next 50 years.
The fact that the
Jackson Pollock of today,
whoever she or he may be,
his family will be
collecting checks in 31 years
- Yeah.
- On a royalty rake on a transaction
makes my heart smile, Darren
in a way that you couldn't imagine.
- Yeah. It's amazing,
With that too, these same artists,
whereas before they were the artists,
you know, in the sloppy clothes with the,
you know, cheap paint
all over their clothes
or whatever and then
there was the collector
and that was a different group entirely.
You now have this mix.
Like I collect art,
I never really collected
her before in my life.
And now I collect it regularly.
- Do you transact on art, Darren?
- I do, yes.
I create art, I sell art.
I sell secondary, yeah.
- Do you buy art and resell it at times
you just decide to do?
- Yes, yes.
- This isn't, the reason I ask that is
that's probably gonna
be the most interesting
thing in the super short term for me,
which is what is the
OG community gonna think about,
what I know is coming,
which is an enormous amount
of collector, flipper,
trader at heart people
who are gonna get much more enjoyment
of buying a piece of art and reselling it
than doing that with a stock.
- Right.
- Than doing that with a currency.
Like for example, I have the same feeling,
like for example, the art I have behind me
Alice Barrett former employee
I support art from a friend standpoint.
- Hmm
- Number one, number two
- Personal networks is key
to networking, it's key.
- I'm just, I'm giving you like,
I am a baseball card comic book,
collectible toy flipper at heart.
I love it.
I love buying, you know
a blue snaggle tooth that came
from the Cedars Cantina set
'cause that's the rare
snaggletooth versus the red suit
and buying that at a
garage sale for four bucks
and selling it on eBay for 200 bucks or
buying it for a hundred bucks and
selling it for 200 bucks later
'cause I thought it was a downtime
for "Star Wars" or, I enjoy that.
I don't like stock market.
I don't enjoy buying a
stock and then reselling it.
No enjoyment.
I love flea market, garage
sales, sports cards culture.
- Well, let me, let me encourage you then
to look into where that really happens
because of course you can
go to the Nifty Gateway,
you can go, I do have
work on known origin,
for example, however I didn't start on
KnownOrigin of course, right.
I started on Rarible.
- I know Rarible very well.
- I started on OpenSea, right?
And that's where you can get
that garage sale type of-
- A 100%, am on those platforms-
- When you find that gem, right?
- I, SuperRare,
OpenSea, Rarible, like
Bitski, I'm watching everything.
I'm watching everything, and right now
(sighs) I'm just very fascinated because
I think there's a huge amount of humans
on earth that share my DNA
that nobody talks about,
which is the following.
That trading component is much more fun
in NFTs than it is in real
estate or wall street.
Number two, and this is where it gets
really interesting for me.
This is a real thing that
I've been doing my whole life.
- You got to tokenize those.
- Are you kidding me?
It's like the thing that
keeps me up at night.
I'm like, oh my God.
In grammar school,
kindergarten, first grade
third grade, sixth grade,
a lot of kids knew me as a doodler
as later people thought I was gonna be-
- I was the same way, I was the same way.
- That I was gonna be an artist,
which never gets talked
about in my narrative,
not something I share.
And you have to watch
my blogs very carefully
and you'll see that I'm doodling
a lot in meetings, right?
So, when this all hit my radar, you know,
that was something that
really got me emotional.
I'm like, oh my God, is this gonna be
like, wow, God literally,
this is something I said,
God, thank you, it's
literally something I said
to myself, six months ago,
God, are you kidding me?
Have you created a technology
that takes everything that I am,
how to build a community,
you know, understanding storytelling,
the doodling component,
the garage sale flipping,
the garbage pail kid,
like it, this is crazy.
This is like
my life's work.
So I've been very cautious and thoughtful
of my entry into this world
because I don't wanna,
I know I have a big platform now.
I'm not who I was the first
couple of times, you know,
- Hmm, Hmm.
- I
definitely,
I definitely
am worried to drive the market.
- Right.
- I'm incredibly scared of that, Darren.
I'm scared to talk about-
- You're scared of creating a bubble,
is that what you mean?
- You know, it's funny.
I'm actually not because I think I'm only
gonna buy and talk about things that
I've decided are 30-year projects.
- Okay.
- So I'm actually not scared
cause I think I'm good.
It's what happened in sports cards.
In the sports cards world,
I've been uncomfortably right.
- Hmm
- And it's because I'm
really darn good at this.
And so I'm talking about NFT as a genre.
I'm not really talking about projects
because I just have more homework to do.
I've you know, I've alluded to
so I'll do it here as well.
I have decided that CryptoPunks
is a 30-year project.
- Hmm.
- And there's been a million articles
and this audience doesn't
need me to explain why.
So I won't spend time on that.
But
no, I'm worried about being perceived
as pumping and dumping as creating.
And so it's, I gotta really be thoughtful
of how I'm gonna navigate
but I'm not actually
scared about the bubble.
I am probably scared
about the macro bubble.
Like when the inevitable shit hits the fan
with all these projects,
I do think everything
gets dragged down with it.
So I am scared to tell friends to invest
in things or-
- Right.
- Because even though I
think Punks is a steal
do I think if in nine months or 13 months
or 16 months there's that crater moment
'cause there's just too much supply
and there's not sustainability
of the secondary demand,
could it go down with it?
I do.
Do I think that's probably one
I'll go most by increasing?
To me, it's April 2000, Darren.
- Yeah! Yeah!
- April 2000
is when the stock market collapsed,
internet stocks and everybody bailed
on the internet itself.
And that's when I tripled
down on the internet
and said, no, no, no,
the stocks might've been overvalued
but the whole genre's going nowhere.
- Yeah.
- And that was when I
bought my Amazon stock
for the first time cause it was like-
- Right, of course.
- And so like that's
what I'll do with NFTs.
When and if, when and if because
just 'cause I think it might, it may not.
But if it does have that moment
that's probably what
I'll go shopping the most
on the things that I've
deemed most meaningful.
But there's so much I mean,
different blockchains and you know, right.
You know, Ethereum, Flow,
There's so much going on there.
Different, there'll be many more.
There's Ethereum scale, wrapping things,
burning things like, you know,
there's a lot to think through.
This is early, early, early days.
- Yeah, absolutely.
What are your thoughts on trash art?
Have you looked at that,
looked at that at all?
- Not deeply yet.
I'm still in the phase where,
because I decided punks was real
that I spend an ungodly amount of time
educating myself there.
- Yup.
- And I'm continuously
spending most of my time
doing stuff like this,
whether in private or public
I want to become friends with
people in the community, I
wanna offer my value to them.
I wanna meet them and I'm still learning.
So I haven't gone, you know, I've done
very surface level stuff with like
HashMasks with
Cryptokitties I've looked at
a little bit for my own education.
'Cause that was obviously like many,
the first thing I've looked at,
Top shot carefully, I've looked at
a lot of the wax stuff 'cause I like
Street Fighter and Garbage Pail Kids.
I've looked at, you know, I've
done my homework on people.
So I've done a little on the
individual artist front, artifacts.
Some you know, the Bitskiprojects.
I've looked at stuff, I've done my random,
like three hour deep dives into OpenSea
and Nifty just to poke around.
And (stammers)
But I haven't yet on trash art but
I'm excited to, and I will.
- Probably one of the best places to
look for that is the
artist that I interviewed
for that piece that I wrote
about called "Immutable Trash".
- You can send me that link after this.
- I will.
- I'll read it over the weekend.
- Yeah, for sure.
His name is Robness.
He's probably the best-known trash artists
along with Max Osiris.
And of course following that,
there's a huge movement of more artists
that join in with that.
And I actually sent you the link to it
in your Twitter, if you want to peek at it
but it's a bit of a read to do
during a conversation obviously
- Yeah, I'm not gonna do that,
yeah I wanna focus on this.
- It wouldn't be practical
- But those two stand out.
Another great place to go if you wanna
find out more about just
that entire movement
in a community building is the art gallery
auction house on telegram, Daniel Penn.
I think Crypto Campfire
mentioned them too,
actually.
- Okay.
- That was actually where I found a home
when I began this as an artist
because I'm coming from a different world.
I'm a teacher.
I teach full-time, I began writing 'cause
I just love writing.
- Hmm.
- And from that I just,
when I saw the crypto arts
I was just like, felt
like what you were saying
where it's like all these different things
I love just came together into this one.
- I even felt-
- I can't stop thinking about like,
I'm obsessed with it.
- Listen, I'm obsessed with e-sports.
I'm obsessed with the cannabis industry.
I grew up in the wine business.
I don't smoke, but I'm fascinated.
I'm obsessed with many micro things.
Things have happened, so
many things have happened,
but I have not felt anything like this
since 2005 when I was like, oh,
the Internet's about to make a big change.
This social media thing,
this is a real thing.
This isn't a-
- This is like third-wave here.
- Yeah, this, yeah. that's right.
I feel like for me it's 95 oh five.
I'm kind of mad that it's not 2015
'cause then they'd be
a nice round numbers.
(Darren laughing)
But it's oh five-nine,
you know, it's 95 oh five-
- It's probably some
Fibonacci thing or something.
- Yeah, probably (Darren laughing).
But, goddamn it's exciting.
And like the, and the
fact that I get to bleed
in my collecting flipping like,
like pop culture, IP,
retro. Oh fuck, it's just so exciting.
- Yeah, it goes beyond that, right?
Like I mean, people get
excited about the money right.
And of course the money's great, like
the fact that a person like, like I was-
- To me, it's not the money.
It's the being right.
- I love being right.
(laughing)
Like, no, but really it's like, I'm only,
I don't wanna be right so I can
tell people I'm right.
It's like a weird game with myself.
- It's a game, I'm winning
the game when I do that.
- Am I right? Is this kid-
- Yeah, it's true.
And I love when people are like, nah, ah
and then, you know, two
years later it's like, ah.
- That's everything to me.
(Darren laughs)
You know, you may know this 'cause
you have a lot of context for me.
It's why I love documenting.
I love, you know, when someone's like,
oh, Gary, you're a fly-by-night
and I can show him my point of view
on virtual goods in 2010.
I don't know if you saw that clip.
- I don't know if it will all
fly-by-night at this
point anymore (laughing).
- Yeah, but you know what,
not fly-by-night, you know what,
people are like, oh, you're
just jumping on this.
- Right.
- You know,
- Bandwagon or something.
- You don't care about NFTs.
Yeah, and I'm like, look
at this video in 2010
when I'm talking about virtual currency
and virtual goods like
this has been on my mind
in some shape or form for
a very, very long time.
It just prime time now.
- It's a culmination of
a number of different elements
- A culmination.
coming together, you know.
- Yes.
- Coalescing. Absolutely.
You know, and but with
that, what I was saying was
the money's great like it's amazing.
I was talking to someone
just the other day
who I forget which country he lives in.
It was a developing country.
And he says to me, this art that I sold
I'm paying my kids' school fees with it.
Like this is like life-changing,
- Game changer.
- For a lot of people.
- I know somebody who
sold a Hashmask in India
to a big collector that is like more money
than his parents have made in five years.
- Yeah, next level, yeah.
You know, the opportunities are huge
but beyond that too, it's this community
and that's maybe a little
harder to see with,
you know the Hashmasks
and the CryptoPunks.
But when you get down into the dirt of it,
as I have as an artist starting by like,
like some other, just sold
my first piece the other day
and it was terrible.
It was, I just took a Bitcoin logo
and I put it into an app called Photomosh
and it melted it and made
it look like a fried egg.
And I called it "Fried Bitcoin", right?
And a guy was like, hey,
is that your first piece?
I want that, right.
It's a great feeling, right.
- It's an intense feeling.
For me, what's been interesting about this
is thinking through the metadata.
- Hmm.
- So I, my project is gonna
be very very interesting.
- Okay.
- And I don't wanna give too much away
but I wanna give you a little something
for our history we'll
look back at one day.
- Very interesting.
- All my time-
- And, I'm assuming,
I'm assuming in your
case you've got people
facilitating this process.
- When you say facilitating,
- What I mean is getting
everything set up,
getting everything tokenized, getting a,
you know, if you're going beyond that,
if you're doing something with smart
contract technology and stuff like that.
- Yes, I'm talking to people and trying to
figure out where I wanna do this
and how I wanna do this.
When, but what's fascinating
is the reason I asked you
when you say, you know, facilitating,
I am gonna draw all 5,555.
- Right, that's a good point to make.
- It's not like some of these people-
- Yeah exactly!
- Who have jumped in
with hiring some artists
and then they say-
- Correct. I am going to,
I am gonna create the stories,
the dynamics and the concepts.
The pipes, and doing it
right, and getting it minted
and getting it, smart
contract properly, yes.
I'm speaking to all the, a lot of people
in the community and trying to figure out
what the right things are.
So anyway-
- Now you said 5500 pictures,
is that what you said?
- Yeah. I'm already giving too much.
So we'll talk about other (Darren laughs)
Edit that out.
(both laughs)
- Seriously dude, should I?
- No, no, it's okay, you can keep it,
but I want you to have the scoop.
But like build-up, don't
play it up too much.
Hopefully, it'll just be
starting getting along-
- It'll be in the tweet,
- Yeah.
- 5500
(laughing)
- But you know, it's, I'm really excited.
I'm excited, I'm excited.
I feel like I know when I find my home.
I know when I'm, the sports
car community, my home
the wine community, my home,
the entrepreneurial community, a home.
This is gonna be a home and
and a home that is gonna
show a different side of me
up from a creativity standpoint
that has always been there.
I've spoken so much about the creativity
of being an actual entrepreneur but,
this one's really gonna be obvious
and I'm gonna enjoy it.
And it's gonna open up a whole new
avenue to my life which I can just feel
incredibly excited about.
- Yeah, it's just an opportunity to be
expressive in a different way, right.
- I also hope I motivate people.
You know, I think I've
got a lot of eyes on me.
I have a communication style that
lamps for certain amounts of people.
And I feel like somebody's going to say,
wait a minute, am I an artist too?
And is gonna fulfill their
destiny of being an artist.
I think what NFT, what social media did
was allowed people to be personalities
and experts that would
have never been that.
Influencer marketing,
influencers have been
art is now a collection of people
who are destined to be lawyers,
but are now known for yoga.
Accountants that are
now known for StarTrack.
And I think NFT
infrastructure is gonna allow
somebody who's destined to be a carpenter
actually now to be an artist.
Someone who's destined to be a
sports agent now to be an artist.
Somebody that was destined to be
a stay-at-home dad now to be a artist.
Somebody that was destined
to be a police officer
to now be a meaningful artist.
The fact that art will now be practical
to a generation of parents,
and encouraged instead of discouraged
is going to be a very
good thing for society.
And I'm excited to see the birth of it.
- Yeah, it's fascinating.
You know, it makes me think about,
I was actually just talking
to someone about this today.
The idea that, you know
we're talking right now
about art NFTs, but in my mind,
I'm anticipating pretty much
anything that is property.
At some point you could theoretically say,
could that be tokenized?
- Well, that's a foregone
conclusion to your point.
I think my passion right
now sit around creativity.
But for example,
every book by any author
that's got any juice is
gonna be launched as an NFT.
Like I've got to rethink
my entire thought process
of signing another book deal.
- Hmm.
- Why would I do that?
I can launch it as an NFT,
make incredible dynamics
deliver actual book on
the back of the NFT,
create incredible
secondary market dynamics.
I mean the world, Darren,
this is a big fucking deal.
- It is.
- I'm gonna sell my-
- I've been trying to tell
people this for two years.
(laughs)
- Well, you've been right, good news.
You know how you like being right?
Good news, there you go.
(Darren laughing)
This is gonna change everything.
Absolutely everything.
I think what's gonna be, what I would
encourage everybody here who's listening
to fall into something
I said the other night
and I'm using it, I like it.
Don't try to convince, have conviction.
And it's very different.
You know, convincing people
is fun
but exhausting and not required
when you're this right.
- Hmm.
- So like people are like,
Gary convinced me about it
and this literally actually
ironically happened today.
Somebody said, convince
me about the space.
I'm like, I'm not going to, here's the
here's how I'm gonna convince you.
This NFT thing is gonna
be one of the biggest
technology shifts in your life.
I'll see you in three years.
I'm not gonna sit here
and try to explain to you
that you don't understand
social currency, human behavior.
Why people wear logos on their clothes.
What happens in a digitized world.
Why people will be curious like
rubbernecking and reality
TV and social media
to know what people have bought
and ledgered that the
Provenance matters incredibly
and always has in our society,
that eliminating the
middle that brings very
little value is a good idea.
And the Internet's been doing it.
Technology's been doing that for,
for its entirety as a term.
Like I'm not, I'm not
gonna do that for you.
I don't need to do that for you.
It's just gonna play out.
Why did chiefs and Indians and cavemen
paint their faces with
colors and have skins
that were like, this has been going on.
This is a foregone conclusion.
So here's my rant.
And I'll see you in three years.
I don't care if you buy an NFT.
I just don't care.
- Yeah. I mean, speaking of Provenance
I think really interesting element of that
a lot of people don't
recognize is, you know,
say if you look at this
Topshot thing, right,
and you think about, okay well
who's hands has this particular
card been in?
- So cool.
- And you can look back and go,
whoa, this was actually in
LeBron James wallet, for example.
- Really matters.
People don't understand.
That's gonna be really cool.
When you meet somebody in 13 years
at an event, instead of going to Google
or Instagram, like many do now,
I think people will go to public wallets
and look at what they've done.
And I'll be like, oh, Darren,
you were fucking on this blah, blah, blah.
Like, you know, people
love to have street credit.
And be like, I knew about Pentera first.
- Like Vanilla ice?
- Yeah, exactly.
(Darren laughing)
Where like, I was early.
like for me, I was early on Notorious BIG,
but do I really have proof,
I don't, but I could.
- Sure.
- I could.
- You could.
- You know,
like, we're, you know,
when someone's like, I
was early on Nirvana.
Were you?
Like now you have, but now in 35 years,
somebody who's early on something
is likely gonna have some proof to it
because that entity, the
band, the influencer,
the person, the thing is gonna have an
NFT infrastructure that's gonna prove.
Could, do you understand the level of
clout Darren, that somebody could have
as being the first person
to buy the first item
that Pearl Jam put out in 1991?
- If you could prove it, yeah.
- Well guess what?
That's the world we're about to go into.
- That's right, irrefutably.
- Irrefutably. So I think
Provenance is gonna be
a currency that matters in an insane way.
I think people are naive.
I told people that online dating would be
the standard in 2000, they laughed at me.
I said that people would buy wine
on the internet in 1995,
they laughed at me.
I told people that they would spend
all their time on Facebook,
they laughed at me.
Playing mobile games, they laughed at me.
Like, all I do is get
laughed at (Darren laughs).
And that's when I know I'm onto something.
And this one is one that's
making a lot of people laugh.
They're like, I'll just take a screenshot.
What's the difference?
I'm like everything.
- Well, I was talking fine art with
Sasha Bailey, he's the founder of My BAE.
- Hmm.
- And he was talking about how
he had experienced with
traditional fine arts.
For example, if you were to say,
look at an Andy Warhol
and it was the real one, Eddie Warhol
and then you had a fake
sitting next to it.
They are indistinguishable.
You can not tell the
difference between them,
you know and that's a problem.
So what do they do?
They go by Providence.
They go, okay, who's hands were,
who had this piece, you know
where is the history of this piece.
And again, that's where the blockchain is
vastly superior as a solution.
- It's not even close.
- Right? Not only that, where are those
Andy Warhol's, they're in a vault.
No one's even looking at the things.
- Correct.
- I go to the New York MET.
I don't know if you saw that,
but I posted about it.
I go to the MET and I
go look at a painting
and I'm like, is this
even the real painting,
or did they just put a replica here
'cause they don't want the real one
to get damaged?.
- Correct. And meanwhile, somebody changes
their profile picture to a CryptoPunk,
and you can go check if they're
the actual owner of it.
You could.
- You can.
- You could.
And then you get into the
monetization of the IP.
Like you look at some
of the entity standards
where you're allowed to monetize something
you buy up to a hundred thousand not like,
there's so much neat stuff.
It's just gonna be neat.
That's like the word
like I've been using the word neat.
Like, I don't know if it brings
me back to when I was four-
- It's a child, it's
nostalgic thing right,
it's neat.
- It's neat, it's fucking neat.
- Well, that's why making
the art for myself as well.
A lot of the art I make
literally makes me laugh
as I'm making it, you know
like there's a joy in it.
And I'm hoping you have
the same experience
with your doodling, (indistinct)
- I mean, are you kidding me?
- There's a joy in it, right?
- I mean, look at
Patient Pig, how can you-
(Darren laughing)
- That's right.
- You know, like, I
couldn't be more excited
to be a part of this.
I am really happy that I've been able
to bring a lot of awareness.
I've had a lot of beautiful DMS
and things like, you know,
I have a big platform
and I'm able to bring awareness to people,
the Flamingo project, or, you know
Felicia sort of, you know, whatever
it might be like it's just really fun.
- Hmm. Let's talk barriers though.
Let's talk problems.
- Please.
- You know what, you
know, Ethereum obviously,
you know, if you're minting on Ethereum
like it's got some technological problems.
- Clearly.
- You know, it's too much success.
- Yep, gas is expensive.
- Gas is terrible, you know.
We had kind of a mini crypto winter
in the art scene where I don't know,
you talked about that you've been
following it for months.
And it was just on fire
in October, November,
come December Ethereum
prices kind of skyrocketed
and all of a sudden people couldn't create
or they could create,
but they couldn't mint.
They couldn't tokenize unless
they were upper echelon.
You know, where do you see that going?
- Too early for me to make a call
that I would wanna look back on and say,
okay, you were smart or you were an idiot.
I just don't know.
That's the honest truth.
I know human dynamics.
So what do I mean by that?
I know that there's an incredible amount
of people that are
building on top of Ethereum
that the network is so vast
that the stakes are so collectively high
that people that are dramatically more
technically skilled than I are tackling it
at ferocious levels.
Now I do think that people are naive
a little bit with L-two and all that.
Like, I think there is some naivete
cause when you want it to happen, you know
I'm thinking a lot about the burning
and wrapping of tokens, you know, like,
listen I would never
have bought CryptoPunks
if I didn't know what wrapping was.
- Right.
- Because I would have been too scared.
Like, you know, I, you know
they're very different technologies
but there was a day where Yahoo
was the only search engine.
- Sure.
- And then Google came along.
And I sit here and say, well,
there could be a
different blockchain, like
- Ask Jeeves.
- Correct, I mean, look how great Flow is.
Roham you know learned a lot,
- (coughs)
Excuse me.
- Being up on Kitties and
the scalable issues and,
you know, Flow, and
there's tons, there's tons
of innovation going on on this. So,
Ethereum scaling issues scare me less
than they did six months ago.
- Hmm.
- Because I have enough
belief that if it doesn't, it doesn't mean
all the assets go to zero.
- Right.
- And I'm a person that
doesn't have the skillset
nor to be honest, the interest
on how the concrete and steel is made.
I like designing the room.
- Hmm.
- Got it?
So I try to stay educated enough
that I can speak to the way I'm speaking
to you where I'm dangerous, right.
I can be a little dangerous
but I'm not the person that's gonna
speak about the technical underpinnings
at the level that so many others can.
What I spend my passion
and time and skillset on,
is the human dynamics
on top of those things.
Now I don't want to get
caught with my pants down
which is why I try to
stay knowledgeable-ish,
but to speak about
scalability of Ethereum,
that is above my pay grade.
(Darren chuckles)
- I kind of anticipate in my opinion,
that we'll get to a point where there's a
level of interoperability,
that you know, perhaps these tokens
are moving from one chain to another.
(clears throat)
I mean, there is obviously
a technical challenge now.
- I think that that is
something that is in the
best interest of everyone,
thus makes me think likely.
- Well, on the flip side you could say,
well, maybe it's more
like the Beta max VHS
situation where VHS dominated because
it simply was the one
that was more widely used.
And you know, you could make
that argument for Ethereum.
- I think you could,
but the speed of technology
advancements are so different
today compared to what it would have taken
for a third, you know, cool.
But that was a one-on-one battle.
If the speed and costs associated
with innovating back then in that game,
might've led to something called PS-nine,
which would have destroyed VHS.
- Sure.
- And I think that's how I look at a
Flow had the luxury of
knowing what Ethereum was.
- Right.
Yup, what do you think
of the whole, you know
kind of there's these, you know
kind of curated scenes for galleries
and then there's the ones that
are kind of the wide open.
Like where do you find
yourself drawn to the most?
- Neither and both.
- Hmm.
- To me both will succeed
of whomever wins.
Right, so you will have
meaningful players in both.
- Okay.
- And then I think you'll have
underlining technology
where people like myself
and others can do it on their own domain
and just have the underpinnings
of the capabilities within it.
- Hmm! Let's bring it to your background
a little bit here.
What do you think it is about this,
you know, you talked
about it a bit already,
but you know you've talked
about your childhood.
What is it about your childhood
like that really clicks
with it, you think?
- That's a great question.
You know, my mother's side of the family
has a very heavy leaning
towards storytelling.
They're just like funny Russian uncles
who get drunk and story-tell,
and I'm like, okay that's something,
(sighs)
being an immigrant and learning how
to speak English by watching "Scooby-Doo",
"Batman", the "Adam West"
stuff and "The Hulk",
the movie staff, you know, the TV staff
TV show, "Dukes of Hazzard",
like a lot of seventies
and eighties IP taught me
how to speak the language.
And I think cemented
my Americana, you know.
Being a merchant trainer, you know
I think this is just the modern
stones and rubies and you know, like gold.
I would've probably been a great character
in the gold rush, you know?
And so
DNA and circumstance
of like I do think the
immigrant can't speak English.
These are the things
that taught me English
and they're all IP, probably
has something to do with it.
I can't really unwrap it, sweet pickles-
- But there's a comfort you
find in that in a sense.
- Yeah, for sure.
And then I maintained it.
Like I loved garage selling my whole life
and buying toys and books and mugs
and T-shirts up IP happy days,
more Mork and Mindy.
Like I just always gravitated to
nostalgia Americana
IP,
that shit.
- Yeah, yeah. Very interesting.
Different question entirely.
Totally kind of a-
- Please.
- Bit of a shift here, you know
I think a lot about how this will change
the way economies work on a kind of
a macro scale, you know.
Any thoughts on that in
regards to, you know.
- Big time.
- You know, it's kind of changing
the way we, we transact.
- I think I will become a central bank.
- Hmm!
- I think humans will have economies built
around them because of
access and metadata.
- Hmm! How does that work
in our current system
without there being a huge conflict?
Or is that inevitable?
- I mean, if you're going super macro
with me around like cryptocurrency
and NFTs versus, you
know, sovereign nations.
- Which is like say, Fiat money versus-
- Oh, I think it's a, I
think it's a big, big deal.
- Yeah.
- I think that there's
inevitable regulation
that is overbearing
and it will depend on how big
the movement is at the time
to see what the counter-reaction is.
I mean, I think the stakes are high.
If you believe that Bitcoin wins,
then you believe in the massive
lack of leverage of sovereign nations.
- Hmm. Or that they just rush in
and they try to have their own
little hash war going on and try to-
- They're going to do that.
- Get as much as they can, right.
If they are-
- They're going to do that.
- I mean, Germany I feel like
is my prediction to go first.
Like I think oh they're gonna.
They're gonna have to-
- Why German in particular?
- By the way, when I say complete
intuitive wild guess of like,
I always think about who's incentivized,
but big enough.
- Hmm. See, 'cause I would lean
towards say something like say Iran
or something like that.
- They already kind of
have their own control
if you think about it, if you think
of Germany as a major player in Europe
where Europe is now kind
of like a third player
in the world behind the US and China,
it's almost like they're incentivized
to do a move to almost like re-energize,
you know, cause don't forget,
that's the part of the
world that was number one.
And I always think there's
some underlining tension
when you use your spot, I think America
losing to China in that global leader
over the next hundred years will be like
an interesting underlining resentment
the way that London and
Germany look at the US.
And so I dunno, I've always had this
weird feeling in my own
game of chess in my head
that if there was a
place that would do this
first and most meaningful,
but that was big enough
to actually matter.
So that's always been my hot guests.
- Are they competent enough to fight it?
- I don't know.
I genuinely don't.
- I often wonder.
- I mean
- I just know,
- I just see a traffic
light system take, you now
2 months to get installed
in my neighborhood
I don't know if they can fight this.
- Yeah, well that
(Darren laughing)
that is a really good point.
In reality, no.
In passing a law that makes things illegal
that would make our head spin, yes.
- Hmm. Well, and that can cause harm.
I don't know if it stops.
I don't think it can be stopped.
- Yeah. I think you're probably right.
I think it's like alcohol.
You can do prohibition
but be prepared for the ramifications
- (chuckles) And be prepared for people
to still be consuming alcohol.
- Correct.
(Darren laughing)
- Yeah, all right. Talk about your hopes.
I mean, you didn't, couldn't give
a lot of detail there about your projects,
but you know, what do you see?
What are you hoping happening here
over the next year here
with your experience
in the NFT world, with your experience
in NFT art, what are you
hoping to see happen?
- By far, my reaction to that question is
the 13 to 27 relationships
I make in this next year.
That mirror, the ones I made in 2006
like the Kevin roses and the MSGs
and the Travis and the
Sockers and Dave Morin's
and you know, just these real friendships.
Mike, you know Lazarus and Belsky like
these real, real, real friendships.
I think I'm gonna make some of
my best friends in my
life over the next year.
- That's awesome.
I know for myself, you know,
just joining this community I've made some
awesome friends that, you know
we connect on a daily basis, you know.
- This is going to be a year
that I make some best friends.
- That's awesome.
Anything, any last words
you wanna wrap up with?
I know you're kinda tight on time.
I'm guessing you are a pretty busy guy, so
- Yes, I definitely appreciate that.
I can definitely, that I'm grateful
that I'm available.
That I'm intellectually generous.
I was so gifted with
the ability to get mine
that I always, that I'm
a person that believes
in like abundance.
So if there's anything I
can be a help to anybody.
I think everyone can win.
And to be thoughtful
on the investing side.
I do think people need to be very careful.
There's gonna be a trillion projects
and there's only so much demand.
And right now a lot of the demand
is from people that are
financially incentivized.
They don't really care about it.
They're gonna buy this thing 'cause
they think in a week
it's gonna be this much.
And that's okay.
I don't judge that.
I'm an entrepreneur, I'm
a capitalist, you know
in the good sense of the world
meaning I want it to be fair.
That's why I love a lot about this.
I think it's pure capitalism.
Like there's, it actually,
a game of who is good
not let's rig the game.
And so-
- It's a meritocracy, yeah.
- It's a meritocracy,
that's such a good point.
I just would tell people
like be thoughtful
because when it hits, when it crashes
or it goes down, you know,
it'll hurt, it'll be fast.
It'll be hard to liquidate.
There's not enough underlining demand
to carry what's going on.
And so you have speculation at scale.
Buy what you like or
really do homework on things you
genuinely believe are gonna work.
For example, every great IP, Darren
that's about to come out,
whether it's "Star Wars",
or "Star Trek", or "Alf", or
"Smurfs" or whatever, right.
I'm gonna look very carefully
on how they built it.
You know, because I can't just say,
oh the Pokemon thing is gonna
crush 'cause it's Pokemon.
If it's sloppy and not thoughtful,
the dynamics won't play out to make it
a good quote-unquote investment.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well then you just have a repeat
of the ICO thing we saw.
- This is gonna be a massive ICO moment,
just so you know, this will be
that the shit-coin like reality is there's
gonna be an ungodly amount of NFTs
that sell for a lot in
the first three months
and go to very small places.
So pay very close attention
to who's behind it.
For example, for me what I'm gonna do is
gonna be with me to the die I die,
which gives me tremendous confidence
in the economics around that ecosystem
back to economies around people.
Unfortunately, I think a lot of people
that have my leverage of
awareness and audience,
I think are gonna go for the quick 3,
4, $5 million score.
And I think that's gonna hurt them
and it's definitely gonna hurt their fans.
And I caution people to be thoughtful
as they continue to navigate
especially these next 24 months.
But these next 24 years in NFT
are gonna be remarkable.
- Yeah, a 100%.
Hey, I really appreciate
you taking this time
and I'm looking forward to your podcast.
I hear you're doing it with
someone else in my community next week.
Now I don't wanna give away
too much about that yet.
'cause I'm not sure if he's even said,
but I'm excited to hear that as well.
And I really appreciate you
taking the time to do this.
I mean, of all the
things you could be doing
with your time right now, why is it that,
you know, this is what you're doing.
I'm curious.
- I like people that are authentic
to the thing that I'm excited about.
- Hmm! That's awesome.
- It could be a lot of fancy people
who are gonna hit me a little bit.
It's already happened.
There will be a lot of super famous
super wealthy, super leveraged,
super strategic people.
There's all the natural
people that I'm friends
with that are also in, and
those are real relationships
but there's something important to me
that if I go into someone's home,
I want it to elite and the
rules are take your shoes off.
I wanna take them off.
So that's somewhere else the other day.
And it kind of feels that way to me.
I want real friendships,
real relationships.
I want to be in this community
for the rest of my life.
And the only way I know
how to do that is to be...
Is to bring value.
I know
that in real life,
that my appearance on your podcast for you
gives you leverage to do
more with your podcasts.
And I want that for you.
- I appreciate that.
- And the number one asset that I can,
the number one asset I protect is time.
- Hmm!
- So to me, writing,
being a $5,000 sponsor
of your podcast is a hell
of a lot less meaningful of
like me knowing the truth
than me allocating this time.
- Right on yeah.
- And so that's-
- I'd be okay with that too.
(both laughing)
- We can have that convo too.
Anyway, my friend thank you for your time.
I gotta run.
- Right on.
Thank you very much.
- Bye there.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care.
- See you in the circles.
I hope to spend real
time in person as well.
- Awesome.
- Take care
- Cheers.
Where do you live?
- I live in Alberta, Canada.
- Love it, love it.
I actually-
- I love New York though.
I had tickets booked.
I had hotel booked.
I had tickets for Hamilton booked.
I was all ready with my wife
to come out there for a week.
- Gonna be going on lot of conferences.
So I'm sure we'll be synced.
- Oh man, I was crushed.
Bye, Okay.
- Cheers.
- Take care.
- YouTube watcher,
what's up, it's GaryVee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more contact, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.